[Music]
well ever wondered how your favorite
retail store quick service restaurant or
a manufacturing facility could forecast
demand or apply quality control well
today we are going to explore how abe's
burger by fictitious yummy burger joint
built and modernized their restaurant by
upleveling their edge technology using
google cloud let's go talk this through
over a burger and some fries because
why not
[Music]
i am priyanka vergaria and this video is
all about
burgers
well it is all about burgers but with a
twist
i am about to show you a demo where we
built an edge solution for a burger
joint called abe's burger
they have got more than 5 000 locations
and they need to deploy and implement
consistent technology at all their
joints are you ready
let's go
now before we dive in let me just say
that even though we're looking at a
quick service restaurant as an example
here the design patterns and concepts
would apply to other scenarios as well
like the hospitals retail stores
manufacturing facilities and more
with that let's dive into apes burger
and what they are looking to accomplish
each apes restaurant has a manager and
the goal is to simplify the manager's
day-to-day job by providing a unified
view of the status of their store
we can do this by using the existing
feeds from cctv cameras
first they would like to identify
abandoned tables which are dirty
in addition they would also like to
leverage camera feeds of drive-throughs
to better understand the wait time per
vehicle
the store manager will leverage iot
across restaurant edge using anomaly
detection to predict potential issues
with refrigeration units before it's too
late
and through the use of iot sensors apes
would like to measure quality control so
they can detect the amount of time food
is sitting in a hot hold
local real time decisioning at the edge
is also very important for apes their
customers expect personalized
experiences imagine a menu board that
highlights areas based on customers
previous interest
forecasting demand in real time is also
very critical for abes to stock up on
ingredients and prepare food
there are many factors to consider such
as local traffic conditions around each
location staffing augmentation and store
sales
evaluating these across each edge
location would be cumbersome but through
the use of cloud technologies we can
centralize logic for evaluating sales
data calculating the expected demand
while pushing these calculations to each
location for real-time decision making
the customer experience is very
important to abe's burgers understanding
when trash bins are full for example is
pretty critical think back to the time
when you were dining in a fast food
restaurant dodging the crowd to get your
trash put into the bin only to notice
that it was already overflowing
using sensor data or local computer
vision we can help avoid this scenario
and these decisions are not always
binary for example if the trash is 75
full but our forecasted demand model
indicates a lunch rush which will start
soon then taking out the trash when it's
almost full may make the most sense
we won't have time to cover each of
these scenarios in this video so we will
focus on two which is detection of dirty
tables and demand forecasting to solve
this we will use anthos for edge for
such large distributed edge use cases
providing management of containerized
and virtualized workloads the central
control of the configuration and policy
management and a single pane of glass
view it removes some burden from the
operations teams
and by doing this we drive business
value for abe's burger in the form of
insights personalizations streamline
operations and workflow management
okay now let's see the demo for abe's
burger
this is a ui that we built for abes that
runs on the edge it helps visualize the
applications running in real time and
it's deployed on top of anthos and to
learn more about anthos and this
deployment check out the description
let's say abes is looking to forecast
future demand for the restaurants and
influencing local dashboard for store
managers
these raw events are crucial to daily
operations so we will stream them to
google cloud
using pub sub we can collect events
across all the 5000 location for abe's
burgers
the json message body includes the raw
events coming from the antho store
cluster
before we can act on the data we need
the ability to store the raw events the
raw events also need added context here
we use data flow to assist the windowing
and aggregation data as it streams
through while combining it with
additional data sets for example we will
add context to each raw transaction to
understand which region and franchise
the event belongs to
also we'll be using data from product
catalog to gather metadata about the
items being sold
is the item part of the combo meal or
kids meal or a dessert item
data flow will also be beneficial
providing windowing and aggregation of
events now corporate dashboards machine
learning models and other applications
will be able to take advantage of the
time series aggregations at minute hour
and daily level
in addition we group the aggregations
based on different categories for abes
we're using data groupings by product
category region and franchise
bigquery ml enables data scientists and
data analysts to build and
operationalize machine learning models
directly inside of bigquery using the
simple sql
now we have built a simplistic version
of demand forecasting for apes burger
using bigquery ml while the production
models would likely be a bit more
complex this is meant to illustrate how
simple it is to leverage bigquery ml for
creating models
here we're building a linear model for
demand forecasting this model takes into
account historical sales patterns per
location and product to build a demand
forecast for a location and items for
specific point in time
now querying these models for future
months provides calculated answers to
questions for apes such as how many
combo meals will store 1100 likely sell
next month
abe's plans to use these calculations
throughout daily operations let's
explore one option for getting these
calculations out to stores for real-time
analytics at the edge
now aids already leverages mysql within
their stores and already has a
containerized version of mysql running
on anthos
leveraging our bigquery model and
scheduled queries we will calculate
demand daily and store the results in
cloud sql within google cloud
we will then leverage replication to
update the demand calculations at the
edge now abe's restaurant demand
application has detected an increase in
demand and we can see this reflected in
the restaurant's ui
looker is google cloud's bi platform
that allows us to combine data from
multiple sources into a single dashboard
here we see the looker dashboard for
apes we can see real-time sales data and
can drill down to get more details
we can also pull in data from social
media to understand the customers better
the dashboard shows abe's chicken
sandwiches have gone viral and everyone
wants one
let's now go through a burger's dining
room cleanliness scenario using some
real world data here's our in-restaurant
dashboard showing no active alerts and
everything is green
here we see our quick serve restaurant
dining room camera and our dashboard
which shows that we resolved all of the
previous actionable status messages
and specifically that all tables are
clear or in use now taking a deeper look
into how this actually works you will
first see the system recognizes that
table 5 is clean and not in use once
people are using the table the system
recognizes people at the table using our
machine learning model and automatically
updates the table status to in-use
the images are captured by the dining
cam pod and runs through the dirty table
inference api which in turn uses both
the predict people and predict clean
table models
once the dirty table inference api has
both results it stores the results in
the database and sends any alerts to the
dashboard via a local queuing system
we used google cloud's vertex ai automl
service to create our dirty table model
we simply uploaded labeled images of
clean and dirty tables in order to
automatically train and test the models
used in anthos at the edge
you can see we actually had a pretty
small number of training images and a
very good recall score
for the people detection model we used a
publicly available tensorflow hub
pre-built model this significantly
reduced the time and cost of deploying
and using models at the edge
that was our fictitious quick service
restaurant abe's burger
why did we choose burgers again well
because who doesn't like burgers
so if you're interested in discussing
the use cases relevant to your
enterprise and see how edge computing
patterns can enable those please reach
out to us at the email described below
[Music]
you